- But it's been 16 years
since "High School Musical".
Do you remember the beginning of that?
'Cause that was your
big first thing, right?
- Yeah. Like I remember all the auditions,
definitely, 'cause there
were a lot of them.
- Oh really?
- Uh huh.
- Oh.
- Yeah. I mean there were like three,
but like, I remember them distinctly.
- You did the same thing with "Idol."
People don't know that,
but there were many auditions
before even got to the TV part.
- Oh yeah, of course.
I like remember meeting
Zac for the first time,
meeting Lucas for the first time.
- [Kelly] Oh wow.
- Me and Ashley had already met
'cause we did a commercial together
like a month prior.
- [Kelly] Random.
- Yeah.
- But it's wild.
The time just keeps flying.
- Yeah. Well you start so young.
That's I think that's
what happens when you-
- Yeah. I'm like I got
decades under my belt now.
- Know it feels weird.
I feel weird saying like 20 years,
that feels weird for me too.
- Yeah.
- But do you ever hear
from like younger kids
just now discovering it?
Because speaking of my daughter,
my kids actually were introduced.
My nanny is in love with you as well.
So she's showed them "High School Musical"
and they love it.
So do you have like little
kids now coming back?
'Cause you're like, that
was a long time ago.
- I mean-
- But they're just seeing it.
- A long time ago.
- I know what they think.
Is it weird?
'Cause my daughter, like she'll see people
and she'll be wait, but
is that the same girl?
'Cause they don't get that
it came out like years ago.
- Totally.
- Do you get kids-
- I mean, I feel like I
kind of look the same.
- You look, congratulations on that.
(audience cheers)
That doesn't work-
- Good genes. Good genes
- For all of us. Yeah. Yeah.
- But yeah, like it's so crazy
because it continues to live
on like for generations.
- Yeah.
- But like that's-
- Especially with streaming things.
- That's like the magic
of musicals, though.
You know?
Like I remember watching "West Side Story"
for the first time when I
was like three years old.
- Yeah.
- And like now there's a new
one for the new generation.
Like musicals, just have
this like legacy about them.
They don't go outta style.
- I think also it has a lot to do,
I mean the story yes,
but also the music is what captivates you
and I know you put out albums
while you were doing that.
So are you gonna do that again?
I like you singing.
- Thank you. I like singing, too.
(audience cheers)
They like me singing.
- Yeah.
- I definitely had to
sit back for a second
and like figure out what
it is that I wanted to do.
- Focus on?
- Yeah. And like, I felt like
if I was gonna do it again,
I wanted it to be like
really authentically myself
and like really be my own voice
and perspective and writing.
And I just like, honestly,
haven't gotten there.
It hasn't been like the main priority.
I feel like if I was to do anything,
like a jazz something
would probably be the first
to come.
- That's cool. I love when people do that.
- I love Jazz.
- Me too.
But I love when people do
unexpected like that, too.
- Yeah. I mean, it's just personal.
Like that's what I listen to.
Like I've always got Julie
London or Billie Holiday playing
at my house and people
are like, "Interesting."
I'm like, "I'm a grandma. I don't know."
- Yeah.
I have some grandma tastes about me too,
but I think it's just called good taste.
- Yes, it is.
- Yeah. I think it's
just like classic sound
that sounds good-
- Yeah.